[Musique]
et c'est avec vous Gabriel Gontier
bonsoir bonsoir On commence ces
informations du jour avec la colère des
agriculteurs yvelinois il dénonce
notamment l'inflation dont ils sont
victimes ainsi que les contraintes
européenne liée à la profession ce matin
une première action a eu lieu dans les
Yvelines oui Mathilde et la colère ne
faiblit pas peu avant 8h30 une opération
escargot a eu lieu dans le secteur de
Oudan à l'appel du syndicat FS des FDSEA
Île-deFrance une trentaine
d'agriculteurs se sont rassemblés sur la
nationale 12 pas de blocage des routes
mais un arrêt pour accrocher une
banderole avec l'inscription suivante
Macron répond-nous hashtagsuf ton paysan
deux radars ont également été couvert de
paille c'est la première fois depuis le
début de la mobilisation que des
agriculteurs se mobilisent dans la
région une nouvelle opération est prévue
demain matin sur la nationale 12 cette
fois-ci dans le secteur de Montfort
lamoris Frédéric rose pourrait devenir
le nouveau préfet des ivelines oui il
s'agit d'une information du média la
lettre Frédéric rose actuel conseiller
intérieur et sécurité d'Emmanuel Macron
et ancien proche collaborateur de
Rachida Dati pourrait succéder à
Jean-Jacques Brot l'actuel préfet
desvelines depuis 2018 cependant cette
nomination Mathilde n'est pas encore
officielle il faudra attendre une
officialisation en conseil des ministres
on poursuit Gabriel avec une information
spatiale oui il y a 3 ans jour pour jour
une fusée Falcon 9 était lancé par
SpaceX en Floride 143 satellites étaient
à bord parmi eux uvsqsat il s'agissait
du tout premier nano satellite français
destiné à observer des variables
climatiques il a entièrement été conçu
au laboratoire du Latmos à Guy en cour
depuis son lancement uvsqusat a effectué
plus de 15000 tours de la terre fourni
plus de 20 millions de télé mesures
livré plus de 3 millions de données
scientifiques on peut voir quelques
exemples à l'image en avril 2023 uvsqsat
a été rejoint par un deuxème nano
satellite celui-ci il s'appelle inspire
sat seven un 3è devrait arriver sera
lancé en 2025 c'est cubsat uvsqsat NG
184 jours avant les Jeux olympiques de
Paris et pour l'occasion la ville de
poissie s'organise oui Mathilde car
plusieurs stars du triathlon poseront
leur Val dans la cité Saint-Louis à
poissie parmi elle le Norvégien Christi
Christian Blumenfeld double médaillé
d'or au jeu de Tokyo et la bermudienne
Flora Jane deffy d'autres athlètes
néozélandais et suisses devraient
également s'y installer pour leurs
entraînements le stade Léo larange et la
piscine de Mignot seront mis à leur
disposition et poiss pourrait également
accueillir l'été prochain un autre sport
olympique le rugby A7 l'équipe japonaise
serait déjà en contact avec la
municipalité enfin Gabriel on termine
avec de la danse le groupe noblas crew
fait la gloire des Yvelines oui dimanche
dernier le club de danse originaire de
mant la Jolie a triomphé pour la 2uxè
année consécutive il remporte le battle
age quality une compétition française de
dance poop composée de deux épreuves
l'une en groupe et l'autre en duo je
vous propose qu'on regarde un
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
extrait
et vous le voyez sur ces images noblas
crew à tout raflé les ivelinois
repartent donc avec une récompense de
2024 € 2024 € pour l'année 2024
peut-être comme l'année effectivement
merci beaucoup Gabriel Gontier pour
toutes ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous voyez une
image ou une information qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous la partager sur les réseaux sociaux
en utilisant le hashtag 7 news